[Music]
number two a
you are facing off against an off but it
is flashed oh what oh
come on ice paper hands you can't you
don't know what i'm doing
like that i know i know your name but
you can't be this cold
i mean i i'm never going to hit like an
off shot through a flash like that so
that was absolutely
nuts and it is a 1v1 and ice paper hands
caps it off with the 3k
takes the bomb down and this man with
this operator
seems to be unstoppable right now artist
was was alleged
to have been taught about match fixing
and cheating
and uh buying uh buying cheats
to to implement right i even spoke to
wright a little bit about all the
situation
um right from what i know writer have
investigated with me as well
raya found that i've done nothing wrong
assistant's coming up from heaven a lot
of damage coming through on top of it
nice shot coming off the hardest to just
double tap those with all
i don't know if he's making a name for
himself anymore i think he's kind of
made it he has just been performing
round after round
to be an artist still holding down the
line it looks like the peak's going to
come through and that's ain't called
quick
double
that's right now artist is
killing it in valor it's going to go
down but that's the trade he drops down
from heaven as well
looks for the op shot brings out the
knives goes up into the air that's right
ice paper hands with the jet proving why
they pick it up on the roster he's been
playing valorant since day one
making a name for himself by destroying
every european tournament that he enters
somebody's got a plant there's the
molotov that barely
avoids the total oh he got the king rice
paper hands just comes around the corner
and grabs him regardless the slow play
the victory lap four fish one two three
and the defuse all at once and in july
artists hit the
jackpot signing with giant or g2 esports
and he joined forces with another one of
europe's best players
mix well simply put right now ardis is
at the top
of eu talent it's all up to sulcus the
silva to keep things going
first peak not going to be his it will
be g2
your champions here of the we play
valerian invitational but before he
could realize his dreams of playing for
such a prestigious org
he had to fight back against some of the
deadliest accusations
in all of pro esports cheating and match
fixing
accusations that date back to his time
playing pro cs go
and not all on the znx and artists left
inside of the site and znx makes his way
in damage done towards the ram player
david p finished off
it's looking like there could be a
chance as soon as i say that
logan gets the kill macca finishes off
the job
like most ballarant pros signed to teams
artist was once a pro in cs go
but he didn't really find the success he
was looking for in valve's first person
shooter
that all changed in october when him and
other struggling cs go pros caught a
glimpse of the next step in their
esports career
valorent project a is our
character-based tactical shooter
it's competitive it has precise gun play
it's set on a beautiful near future
earth
and it has a lethal cast of characters
for many people valerian looked like a
fun new first person
shooter but for some it was a second
chance at esports glory
a second chance that artists wasn't
about to waste
[Music]
almost immediately after valerian hit
closed beta artists joined a team named
fish123
and shortly after joining the team they
won their first tournament
dodges a little bit of it as a few slow
orbs left the spring alex not enough
bullets switches over
characteristic fashions look so strong
take the upset over the dominant nip
fish 123 dominated the european
ballarance scene throughout the first
few months
with artists establishing himself as
arguably the team's most deadly member
especially with the operator in hand but
there's that neural theft
the plant will come down and cheer up
beautiful timing they're so unfortunate
for bureau
preparing to join g2 as a fourth member
of their ballarat roster
artist was about to make the jump to a
tier one org
but before he could do that he was
accused of cheating
and match fixing two of the worst things
a player can do
in a game it's crazy to think that we
are so
young into the scene and we already have
an allegation like this
as we as we talk about this with the
artist drama of course uh
had been playing with fish 123
and now he has allegations made against
him
uh of match fixing midway through june
it's gamerdock who's a cheating and
cyber security expert when it comes to
esports
wrote a medium post accusing artists of
cheating and match fixing
the article uses an old video as
evidence in which
artist discusses the idea of cheating
and match fixing artists
quickly responded refuting the claims he
admitted that he had listened to a
demonstration from cheaters due to
financial hardships
but he never actually went through with
it for a pro
cheating and match fixing can kill your
career just look at brax in the eye by
power guys
so everyone was waiting to see what
verdict riot would reach on
artists i just want to say to this point
right like i think
that i'd be surprised if ryan's not
looking into this after
after that article um and i don't think
that we'll see artists get signed until
riot clears them and just a week later
artists announced he was cleared by riot
proving his innocence he was exonerated
free to continue pursuing his dream
invalorent he's continuing to flourish
in valon
g2 are the kings of europe and artists
has yet to lose a best of three in this
new pro scene
i can give a [ __ ] what people think that
i mean
oh yeah 10 and 10 finals okay 10
in 10 in battles not lost the best of
three in the in the hall of balance
hey include the debater including the
beta
i have not lost the single best of three
i i walk on board for this game simple
as
simple as
water thanks for watching if you want
more content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages
you